أنت تعلم أنني بحاجة إلى الحصول على رد فعلك على
هذا السيد الوزير بوتين الذي وضع
قوات الردع الخاصة به كما يسمونها
ترسانته النووية في حالة تأهب قصوى ، أعني أن
أوكرانيا ليس لديها
قوة نووية ،
هذا مجرد قعقعة ما يحدث
في
جيم
الثاني.  قال هنا كدليل
ضعف وليس علامة قوة
أه
إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام فلن تكون
هناك حاجة له حتى لإثارة هذا ال
وع من ال
هديد للعالم وأوكرانيا أه
ن الواضح أنه يحاول إرسال إش
رة إلى  الولايات المتحدة
ولحلفائنا في الناتو
ولكني أعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا
أن أه بوتين يجب أن يفهم
مدى قوتنا عندما يتعلق الأمر بالردع النووي
أه لدينا رادع نووي ثلاثي الشعب
يمكنه الرد على أي
تهديد وأعتقد أنه  من المهم أنه
يفهم
أنه إذا حاول فعل أي شيء
قد يتضمن أسلحة
نووية ، فهو لا ينهي
عهد بوتين فحسب ، بل نظامه أيضًا.